دعونا مشاهدينا نتعرف معكم الان على
الهيكل التنظيمي لحركه طالبان في
افغانستان حيث يتولى هبه الله اخوان زاده
قياده التنظيم تولى زعامه الحركه منذ عام
1916 ويعد المرجع الاعلى للحركه في الامور
السياسيه والدينيه والعسكريه الرجل الثاني
في طالبان هو رئيس الوزراء محمد حسن اخوان
هو نائب رئيس الوزراء ابن فتره حكم حركه
طالبان الاولى بين عامي
و2001 ثم عاد ليراس حكومه طالبان في
السابع من سبتمبر 2021
سانتقل الان الى الشخصيه الثالثه في
القياده هو عبد الغني برادر وهو احد
المشاركين في تاسيس الحركه يشغل برادر
حاليا منصبه نائب رئيس وزراء حكومه
الطالبان ويعتقد انه كان في الانفجار الذي
وقع في مزار شريف شمال افغانستان سنواصل
الان مع الهيكل القيادي لطالبان لنصل مع
سراج الدين حقاني هو زعيم شبكه حقاني
وتولى لاحقا منصب وزير الداخليه في حكومه
طالبان ونيابه زعامه الحركه نائب اخر
لقائد الحركه هو محمد يعقوب وهو نجم مؤسس
الحركه الملا عمر ووزير الدفاع في حكومه
طالبان افغانستان